Should I have any wide if I have cancer in the liver small spots?
I just want a glass of wide now and then
So is any alcohol a
Good thing to take for somebody who has cancer
No, alcohol is not a good thing to take for somebody has cancer and it's no neuter-to-value
Wide is got
Resveratrol in it. Lots of neuter-to-value
Especially if you have cancer that's metastasized to the liver. I would not personally be very keen why not again
Well, if I just had a glass of wide at my birthday party and a glass of wide at New Year's four months ago
And a glass and I'm doing a glass of wide a month. Okay, you're within reason, right?
and
But to like I want a glass of what I had one person once I just I drink some wine. How much wide? Just just one a day
What literally they finally had to drag it out of them. They're drinking a bottle of wine a day
Okay, that's way
One glass of wide a day is too much and if you've got cancer, especially if you have cancer in the liver
You just don't want to tax your liver detox pathways even more. I would say just within reason, but I would be careful with that
And I would say just within reason, but I would be careful with that